die angeblichen leaks strategische
US-Dokumente was halten wir davon und
wie hat sich dadurch die Lage geändert
die kurze Antwort wenig und kaum die
lange Antwort was meint ihr wie
wahrscheinlich ist es dass es sich
wirklich um ein echtes Lied handelt sind
sie nicht eher Teil einer ausgeklügelten
psychologischen Operation um den Boden
für eine ukrainische gegen Offensive
zubereiten nun sowohl die Ukraine als
auch die USA fahren eine massive
Desinformationskampagne um die
russischen Entscheidungsträger maximal
zu verwirren was ihr mehr darüber wissen
wollt Abonniert jetzt visualpolitik und
erfahrt die wahren Fakten zu den leaks